[Music]
hey Kevin hello man hello everyone
let me just fix that how's everyone
doing and I got my trainers here very
nice
yes hoody guy is the special guest well
it's it's sort of a potential special
guest it's not I've never actually had a
guest on stream so I don't know if it
will work but I guess it's it shouldn't
be all that complicated so we are
continuing with the Friday arena's we
have the meadow arena first and then the
other matter Friday arena and the meadow
arena already started so we're going to
join in hello everyone once again and
yeah let's check out a few games so for
the moment a lot of you meadow is
leading the meadow arena but that game
is already well on its way so we're just
gonna tune into some different game
let's say this one which is almost on
its way when we'll do a runescape line a
livestream start I I have no idea is the
under guest no it's not young as a yawn
is chilling somewhere on the seaside all
right so what do we have here some sort
of a a scotch
a scotch game between quality qualia and
smashers measure our argit
alright let me just fix that okay for
the first time in a long time the stream
health seems to be healthy full healthy
green so that's that's very nice alright
yes like I said we had the Scotch here
and now okay it's at remaining games of
day they've advanced a bit far and black
is up the exchange so that's that's good
for black and we'll see if he will be
able to push it all the way ok so going
for that pawn white also would very much
like to attack the king side so we'll
see we'll see what happens all right so
nicely attacking the rook also also
probably preparing rook c6 the window
Knight
so like rook c8 might not be might not
be a terrible option here it's not not
an easy position for white and no one
berserk as of yet yeah so now it's the
same because the Queen and worked nicely
connect but you could now go yeah you
can't yeah that doesn't really work yeah
I think it's I think this is this is it
for white
yeah Misha no it's not Misha Misha is
not a special guest
please don't private the stream what
does that mean what does privately the
stream mean alright and that's a nice
checkmate so smasher
Arijit checkmates quality qualia good
job man alright so let's check out this
is a new user
I called love you meadow playing against
bad player is playing so it's let's see
if meadow can take on a bad player over
here Articuno hello man how are you
doing
alright alright sorry just taking care
of something there's a there's a special
video that we that I will be publishing
after the stream so I'm just making sure
that everything is ready Nicholas why
not stream on Twitch it's actually
something that I've only recently
discovered I've recently discovered that
if you get partnered on Twitch and you
start streaming on Twitch you can no
longer a stream on YouTube it's not like
I know before you couldn't stream on
YouTube and twitch simultaneously but
now if you stream to which sorry if u
stream chess on twitch twitch no longer
allows you to stream chess on youtube so
i doubt i will be switching over to
twitch anytime soon have I heard Joe
Rogan talking about chess I I haven't
but I will check it out was it from from
some new podcast or was it just like
standalone a video kind of thing
yes YouTube is the is the real platform
well said well if I told you who the
special guest is it wouldn't be very
special would it is it the podcast video
no it's not the podcast video we will do
the podcast video next next week all
right so let's see bad player playing
against love you meadow and ah made of
berserk so let's see if he can do it and
he's a very long time and also a bad
player really putting putting pressure
on meadow why is it about 17-hundred why
is what above 1700 his meadow arena
close no this is the meadow arena only
you can't you can't join if you are
rated above 1700 that's that's the
problem
yeah and of course the links as usual
are in the description below so just
click on the link and you join and now
of course it's a flag off as every great
game ends in a flag off that's how it
works
and now it's mate almost but not really
and two seconds for meadow can meadow do
anything here that point is really
tricky however and will it be made yes
it will be made that player delivers
mate with less than a second on the
clock for meadow so that's first first
loss for meadow and we're gonna check
out some other games from our top
ranking players and then we are going to
check up on some other games no yeah it
was it was a good one but meadow
couldn't couldn't deliver all right so
it's Giacomo the liberally versus the
tici tici something
ah that's the first thing you heard when
you joined the stream
yeah that's not really the real middle
all right so black avoids the Queen
trade as well he's a for a moment the
material is equal so nothing nothing all
happening there seems to be a very very
reasonable game as our thanks a lot man
you hoped I would cover NIM versus hutch
I couldn't cover all of them at the I
saw these two first and I decided to go
with it with those two was it like was
it like really good ah he's down a rook
was he always down a rook or did he
blunder a rook yeah okay being down a
rook will will be a bit problematic yeah
material is equal except that white is a
baroque that that is what I meant yes no
I did not watch watch that finale
what was the Elena's cake like it was it
was excellent we we couldn't we couldn't
get enough
yeah the mic was covering the rock and
not really I can't I can't blame the mic
this time because well the white player
is up in this game and white is up a
rock
when will the guests come I don't know
when when he or she comes then the
guests will arrive
what do you mean the tournament is above
1700 if you are above 1700 then you
cannot be join it's always like that but
it's only for the first tournament for
the second one you can be rated as much
as you want and you will be able to join
can I pronounce your name Pratyush
Prakash I hope that was hope that was
okay
Breann sure thank you for the
contribution man thanks a lot khadiyah
yes if you are above 1700 then you
cannot join that that is what I said
okay and if you are below 1700 and still
can join it means that you haven't
played that minimum required to join the
tournament as you can see Oh No
it says that yeah I didn't put a
requirement for this game so it
basically if your lower ridden than 1700
you can play but not like if you were
above 1700 yesterday and then just
lowered your rating on purpose for today
then it doesn't work they have a like a
safety system for that cops to park our
thanks for the contribution and who is
the special guest rocket thanks for the
contribution but I will not I will not
be disclosing who it is as it's still
like a 95% percent thing that we will
have a special guest but hopefully we
will we will
I got matter best now that is a good
handle that is a good handle that's how
you you get your game showcased no I
don't think there'll be a classical NATO
arena
yeah I might stream something on Twitch
I just don't think it will be chest
I might stream something else on Twitch
but yeah like I said if you if you want
to get partnered up with which you
cannot play two games on two different
platforms so it's weird
yeah well okay if the mailman arrives
it's not that big of a deal like if I'm
streaming but when I'm recording then
it's like really really weird actual bar
and library vlogs yeah that's something
is something to consider definitely is
the guest a grand master yes that that
is correct
what is this interface what what do you
mean
all right so that's a that's a juicy
beep on what can what can I do here
probably bring the other rock here once
the bishop moves and okay now this is a
free pawn so it wasn't all that juicy
yes I do have plans of course for the
next pot because the next podcast will
be next neck next Wednesday yeah next
Wednesday
is the guest Donald Trump no no it's not
our one-minute matches real chess I
would say yes I would say yes I've seen
some one-minute games played to
perfection and well okay now the
question is do you grab this probably
you do however maybe 30 seconds still I
don't know but if two players are
incredibly strong they will play a very
nice game regardless of the time so it's
not it's not much different like if you
play a three minute game and then you
really take your time to go into the
endgame and then you both just have one
minute left for the entire endgame so
it's basically the same Hey
chess guy hello man yes the pogchamp
final sister day a void boy boy boy is
taking on the mighty hutch captain Raj
pal the link that the tournament is in
the description below as as always so
first link is to the meadow arena second
link to the Friday arena the main event
doing well chess guy how you doing man
avoid boy is going to win I will see I I
definitely consider him the favorite but
you know it's just anything can happen
I should try a podcast with players I
will do that it's a good idea
all right so master baguette versus
agamotto best one still going on with
black being up a piece but white well
it's 30 seconds for both now the rookies
under attack okay now you've
successfully offer the Queen trade and
he goes for it
he might not have been the greatest of
options considering you're down apiece
but we'll see how it goes
oh yes that's what happens and guess the
bread guy still still great okay that's
a free bishop again almost yea the
lockdown in Croatia is really well
hope hope it stays that way
ah the immortal ad game yes okay and
again it's a flag off and yes master
baguette gets flagged that's what
happens and our matter is best takes the
win do I still go to the bar in the
library of course it's my it's my go-to
location all right so let's see some
other incredible least strong players
made of 1700 another user trying to get
showcased we'll definitely check him out
but that games already over so maybe
maybe on our next you know passing
through all right we already seen this
what's this lagi logic in let's check
this out versus Reza metalli
or as a moat i am i famous in creation
no not really and no I do not smoke I
did smoke for ever a long time but I
quit some to a two and a half years ago
yes
meadow is a multi accounting while also
sleeping on the sofa he's he's you know
capable like that beeping thank you for
the contribution man very very very glad
to hear that
can I please tell what is pock champs
well pock champs for those of you who
don't know is that tournament being
played on chess comm between popular
streamers such as voyboy box box Nate
Hill there's a full sleeve chuckle bars
hutch and a lot of other guys and they
are playing some some reasonably good
chess some more than others but it's all
good fun and people are people are
enjoying it I would say
[Music]
what would i rank myself in chess from
one to ten I would say maybe a solid
three
how old is May the meadow is very old he
is like ancient
he's like 14 and something do I have a
favorite chess set no not really I just
don't I just don't like the weird ones
like make the pieces look normal and
that works for me like Dubrovnik set or
maybe a maybe a Staunton or I don't know
pretty much anything that doesn't really
just exaggerate the the look of the
pieces are we going to have a chess quiz
again that is a very good question I am
planning this for a very long time now
but it's not easy making it since the
problem is when I ask a question and you
guys reply in the chat you see that
you've answered first however I see
someone else answered first and then
it's not maybe the the greatest of the
interfaces to use for such a quiz if I
had like an app for that or something it
might be might even consider doing it
like on a weekly basis but also it's
something that I I would really enjoy so
probably will have something like that
in the future okay now there could be a
potential checkmate here with something
like this if the King covers this square
maybe wife can do something you know in
that fashion sense he black still didn't
develop any any of these guys
all right I will now try to implement
the guests if it will be possible we'll
see
[Music]
okay still trying to accomplish this all
right
hello can you hear me is it is it
working let me just check one more time
yeah I don't I don't have the audio so
let's just try this one more time
[Music]
[Music]
haven't haven't tried this before so
sorry if it's taking a bit longer okay
it's taking a bit longer that's why it's
[Music]
alright
huh
okay that's odd let me just check if
this is still working
all right let's let's pick another game
all right there azimuth tally let's
check let's check this one
[Music]
all right
[Music]
how do I get the sound how do I get the
sound let me just check one more time ha
ha ha all right
all right still still trying to figure
it out so let me just try one more all
right we do have another yeah can you
hear me now
yes I can let me just add like can you
hear me
uh yeah I do but I just wanted to change
it for the mic is it uh can I just try
to yeah I think yeah it should work I
guess yeah sure thing now the sound is
okay right
yeah the sounds are actually great okay
so it's fine let me just try and get
this in like a display capture just
trying to get you trying to get you in
there all right let's go here whoa no
not there how about if I have to try it
like this okay
all right we will fix this soon try it
like this so it's taking a bit longer
but oh it's okay it's okay
of course I mean all these things are
complicated that's why I'm actually
struggling with all this stuff yeah all
right so I might be able to do it like
this yeah maybe like that all right
whoops almost almost have it so let's do
it like this all right
yeah I think this will work now I think
my eyes are enough there yeah oh the
emotion okay almost almost yeah okay so
I think best way to do this is if I just
share you my screen so you see what I
see and then we can be so it's in the
Parliament but I can also look through
the streamer it's better yeah Barry or C
I guess yeah it's better if I just show
you the screen since you will experience
lag okay so we don't see your name but
we do know your name so I think that
works okay so let me just check if this
is now okay yeah all right let me check
this or okay so now we've lost you well
we've lost you I don't know why it's
it's a weird it's a way okay do we see
you now I guess we do I don't know I'm
trying to get okay I think I've figured
it out I'm gonna make this smaller so I
can only read the chat I haven't used it
so far so yeah that's that's what I'm
saying I mean it's tricky but OBS is
easier much easier in general or during
it obvious right yeah yeah I'm doing
with the OBS okay so I think I've
made it work now let me just check with
the chat is everything working chat yeah
and can you see and hear a tamer yeah no
I can see only the sign this YouTube
share got matter no no I know you can't
see me because my camera cannot work on
both I think yeah but I mean I don't see
the borders share screen okay no no I
will share it with you now I'm just
checking with the chat if everyone can
see what they say they are you okay yeah
now now I'm going to share you the
screen alright so this is more okay so
now I I'm having some problems finding
the share screen it was there a second
ago
okay I'm just gonna have to yeah it's
like the main screen yeah yeah okay so
maybe it's here nope
let's just check okay I have to enlarge
it once again share screen all right
let's go share screen and this is the
one
sure sure computer sound you don't need
that up to my screen okay can you see
now what's happening on my screen
oh let me see yeah I can yeah so now you
see everything I'm doing yeah yeah
alright so now I just have to bring you
back so others can see you takes a bit
tweaking
sorry about that
and there we are sorry alright let's
just fix that okay so I think we'll be
ready for it in the future
oh yeah okay first that's right off I
think that's that's gonna do it alright
so I just have to bring this back well I
totally need a third screen or two
screens is not enough simply all right I
think we've we've done it alright so you
say you can see everything that I can
see oh yeah
so hello Timur thanks for joining me and
how are you man yeah hi hi I'm fine
thanks for inviting me
no everything's good yeah preparing for
the Magnus tournament and like you know
growing my hair because nobody else I
mean almost all players that are there
in the final and final stages and so on
they are having a huge hair so yeah you
don't wanna be paralyzed the guy yeah
you don't want to be the guy with the
least hair that's not yeah no way to
play with the list points and list here
but the tournament is kind of super
stronger this time is like top eight
players out of top ten so yeah it's
going to be tough here for everyone yeah
almost like the candidates huh yeah
especially our group yeah I mean it's in
our group is like all the candidates
more or less right there yeah who who
are you playing first I'm playing
against nip ominous chasing oh that's
gonna be a a wild one yeah but there is
no huge difference he knows like
everyday is the kind of name that
everybody knows and yeah hard opponents
and used in all this you know the rapids
and blitz and now online everybody's
experienced as well also the streamers
you know the super strong diverse like
the karo and these guys are there
Napo is no streaming as well so everyone
is training almost every day but are you
allowed to stream while playing such as
wrong no no Isaac not yeah yeah it would
be pretty weird yes but later maybe
commenting yeah I'm pretty sure that
that will be possible okay so now
we are going to check if you see a game
you like if you see a name you like just
stop me and we're gonna check out their
game and yeah let me just check I need
one that's only starting all right what
is this is it like the the points
working is it possible to see the
understanding sit order yeah yeah these
are the standings but we it's only just
started so we're not focusing on oh okay
yeah yeah it's a mess
how would you spell that school it
really started from this how would you
will yeah how would you approach this
one down yeah for white wow you already
spotted that I mean he's taking too many
holes I would just go with for something
like Bishop g7 you know especially in
blitz okay you know not to get under
some kind of fixed because you just go
for sure Devon and Castle short might be
a bit too greedy no but it seems fine
yeah because after this 94 I think the
greasiness is now is now a good thing
you know he took me yeah now it will be
certainly hard for whites to keep this
and yeah this is lost their company so
yeah I think any anything can still
happen
well in this one as well you sure yeah
it's a wild tournament always yeah okay
but let's say I don't believe that this
one can end badly for black alright it
takes Bishop d6 we have four yeah I mean
immediately going for mate
yeah he's following our and I was this
yeah
but they can ordinary they have I think
a 15 second lag okay no no this is the
crucial moment yeah yes we'll have to be
do insane yeah okay but now that I think
it's like it's safe traded like should
win the game at least yeah I think he'll
go for your queen F for play yeah but
you can be one is it hang
as well like win a four yeah it is yeah
so no this one is nothing I think enough
advantage sheer finish to these
positions are also like you think
they're still tricky
there's no not really this one looks
yeah why it looks like they're doomed
here it's just no chance ah someone says
it's actually a five-second delay not a
15-second delay whatever yeah I thought
that when you stream there's like a
fifteen seconds delay so you know the
players cannot hear mostly what you
comment on in what wartime formats but
someone just mentioned that it's now
five seconds but I don't think if this
is if this is correct but they can hear
us
yeah yeah yeah oh okay so how do we
mention the best ways should we say bad
moves then no no because they would have
to spend too much time if if they were
waiting you know for the comments yeah
yeah yeah but this one is like he's in a
diary attack beside that everything is
like just lost yeah yeah and 14 seconds
yeah yeah yeah also can flag him and
just give up one piece after the other
it's like you know but it's mating you
and rook takes beefy okay oh it's
lighter yeah
is it leader or is it where we can check
no the leader is a chess hater actually
oh yeah that's that's right yeah he
plays every tournament and always is I
think in the top three yeah all right
let's check out some of the leaders
maybe ok made already we've checked his
game Trevor I got fans from Poland all
right let's check out check out his can
you just explain what is this like but
at the points is it like what is this 34
and stuff is it's not the points I guess
yeah yeah it's the points it's it's the
arena it's not
Swiss system or something like that
whenever you finish a game you instantly
play another game and you need to win as
many as you can in 55 minutes that's how
that's how long it lasts so it's like a
you know free-for-all just brawling it
off with everyone yeah yeah like a very
very wild alright here we have a again I
got matters going on no but this one
already looks fun yeah he's immortal
spotted Bishop captures h3 yeah but now
Knight takes e5 was it possible some
kwinda sticks and stuff probably or okay
now it's just Spencer even Queen takes
f6 was winning but this one is too much
anyway yeah that's nice where where
exactly are you currently I am in Baku I
mean in general I'm living in Azerbaijan
in Baku so yeah so it's just normal with
the situation to be home and how is the
situation there well it was great but at
some point I mean it started to get
worse and now it's like they'll be like
curfews and all that stuff and you know
the you have to give some kind of the
sense of kind of SMS to get out for like
a few hours and so on so it will be
strict from now on unless the situation
is getting worse so yeah you cannot
leave whenever whenever you please no no
you will have to send an SMS and then I
mean with your like passport details and
stuff then you get this permission for a
few hours to get out and you know to
walk or whatever you have any kind of
activities to do and then you should be
back by by the two hours limit time time
limits so yeah that is is it a free SMS
yeah yeah it's a free so that's okay
it's not the subscription yeah yeah it
would be terrible if they if they try to
make money on that as well no no but
yeah that would be too much but so
generally this is the this is the
situation now but yeah but for chess
players in general it's more or less a
common situation you know when you are
at home and it's maximum two hours that
you live you live your apartment for
some activities and maybe preparing for
some tournaments you leave for more to
make some sports kind of stuff like that
and you know but it's just generally
with some Pleasant when you don't have
this possibility you know once you don't
have this freedom of decide yeah yeah
and so on this is the immediately we
wanna go yeah yeah immediately you want
to go for like ten hours outside yeah
but do you get like more done now that
you have to be at home more oh yeah yeah
especially chess wise you know like
having a lot of time to study and so on
and also like playing more online but
generally and playing only chess with
with anonymous account for the moment
yeah but also want to start to play on
the other platforms more I mean to get
used because the boards are different I
mean the thing are different in general
when you play on different platforms
Union I mean probably experience City
all the time when playing it's like it's
very simple and easy to understand and
like you know all these navigations and
stuff and yeah so it's fun to play there
as well and also Carlsen playing there
all these bullets and stuff so it's fun
you know once you finish the game
Cardinals playing like almost 24/7 so
yeah yeah have some fun watching
he has like I don't know he played like
200 and something bullet games against
penguin like I think it was yeah ago but
also like between the games between the
tournaments between the games not but
between the tournaments like like a
between the matches in this
qualification and all this you know on
Lions yeah he's just playing the bullet
until the early morning and I mean
Norwegian time so it's yeah myself I
also like sometimes to play like 4 or 5
3 a.m. and so on but
yeah for during the tournament usually
other players are trying to take rest
and so on
but not him yeah but it's yeah it's you
know it's a new trend there because he
car is always there as well after their
matches and so on he's always there like
online playing and so on yeah that's
cool that's cool
yeah but sorry that's not changed here a
lot I mean compared to the previous
times when we were you know playing the
bicycle tournaments so you would see
magnets on the tournament usually he
would not appear much online yeah and is
it also one of the reasons why you
started recording because you're now
more at home yeah more at home also
having more time also I wanted that I
mean at some point to look at my games
in general like this World Cup games and
so on so I was kind of thinking I mean
what's the best moment to do this I mean
just have this time and it's one of the
last tournaments classical tournaments
have played before this all this
situation started so yeah I just decided
to do it now I mean I think there is no
better time certainly during the
tournament's probably I will have a bit
less time but I will see I all tried
still to do some videos I mean maybe on
on the you know like a recaps or
something like with because I'm these
emotions you also forget them I mean one
one thing is that if I do the video
let's say just right after the game and
just immediately show all the lines I
have seen during the game and then for
example show what was happening and what
is the best
according to compy and so on and another
thing is like when the time passes then
it's it's different you know it's like
you have to do it while it's hot just
after this after the game is played and
then it's like it's more emotional it's
more clear about your souls what were
the mistakes and so on but otherwise
when the time passes then you see
differently from different perspective
certainly and the computer shows you the
best ways and so on and you don't
remember exactly what you were thinking
during the game sometimes some things
you do remember but certainly not as
good as after the game you know
especially there is a there is this
moment of like you know considering your
time what you are doing during the game
how was your emotion the exhaustion is
on so it's very different here of course
calmly sitting at home
looking at the games with with the
support of engine trying to remember
what I was thinking during the games but
it's it's really different certainly it
will be great right after like I mean
Hikari is doing for example he's doing
like almost after every round so this is
this is great I cannot imagine it for
the moment at the classical tournament
when you've played for example like for
seven hours or less against yeah I
imagined after my Thai break against
ding it was like it was like night like
no it's like maybe 11 12 or something as
it still had to go for the doping test
as well after that as well like few
hours because of the stresses and all
that stuff and yes also had to beat for
this I didn't eat like the whole day and
after that I can't imagine going and
recording the video but let's say the
next day would be would be a perfect
time to do this and to have a recap on
the mesh so yeah but now you're having
more time for so I'm trying to still I
mean experience this moments again and
see what's going on it's also the
objective points of you know of all the
games and so on so you analyze it like
deeper when you now analyze it for a
video then then maybe that you would for
just analyzing it for yourself I yeah I
mean let's say like 10 years ago if
we're back in this a bit but maybe 10 15
years ago when we're a bit more to this
classical type of chairs that you have
to analyze your game understand all of
your mistakes where you know and stuff
like that you will analyze it maybe a
bit more than we do like in the modern
times because there are first of all so
many games are so many things to analyze
like in the openings like to improve and
so on so you kind of can't spend like
four hours analyzing your game more or
less it would be a waste of time I mean
unless you're working like 20 hours per
day but yeah I mean trying to trying to
analyze more of course for the for the
videos I do but let's say if if another
tournament and I try to analyze of
course it's it's more kind of you know
kind of fast fast kind of analysis not
it's not as deep as for the
videos because on the tournament
generally goes through the through all
this important moments in the game where
you didn't catch the right moment where
it isn't you see this and that or
checking some lines that you didn't like
during the game or you were sure in and
then you see that corner shows you that
it was just strange miscalculations in
fact and so on and then you get kind of
picture you know about what was
happening so you get more a more the
general picture of what what has
happened and where were the crucial
mistakes and here in general I do I mean
I analyze more or less all the lines
that interests me during the analysis
you know so it's kind of different angle
quite far in general while looking some
some positions and some tactic line that
interests me even if it's to computer
ish and so on so the ones that you would
dismiss in the analysis during the
tournament so it is kind of different
yeah the Turner's would be a kind of
brief notes yeah so yeah but there oh
yeah
so procreate let's go and that's that's
all the delays I don't think he heard it
I think alright next game we show I'm
going to let you do all the commenting
and I'm just gonna read some of the
questions as I see they are asking a lot
of questions for you so I'm gonna
transfer them to you but after the game
okay
is this a podcast no this is like this
is like a casual casual thing okay Rudy
eight oh yeah maybe Quincy three first
yeah Rudy eight was also kind of funny
yeah okay oh this one is winning but
this oh look a fun was it bishop takes
off one there no it's okay I always
thought it was a flag off they were both
yeah I always do this I mean I give some
kind of unexpected checks and to win the
bullet game if I'm up on time because
flagging flagging is also the win you
know in in such games it's the best kind
of win yeah it's especially when you
were lost as throughout the game
yeah just give some few expected checks
and you see how the time is just passing
the time of your opening okay that was
actually the last game from the meadow
arena and now we start with the the big
tournament so here's a love you meadow I
love you meadow takes the first place
followed by unrated boss and remove a
king in third followed by the top 10
chess hater Louis silletti
3k buzz Oh Maddie
Shiva Manny Pato bad player is playing
in chess world 161 - who is a frequent
player of the tournaments and now our
next one our next one starts in like
minute and 20 seconds so we're gonna
give you a good one to start off with oh
the okay I say oh there is one
24:51 is in the players yes yes so to
the Phaedo master or is it like just -
oh yeah it's the radio guys you know
yeah yeah clear okay when do they start
in one minute okay in one minute so you
play with a with a secret account and
leeches do you play like blitz or yeah
boss in general like I mean bleats
bleats and bullets as well oh you also
play bullet sometimes because I mean
sometimes I don't
sometimes I mean I do a lot of bullets
in general when I feel that I can be ok
with my mouse and then yeah I've ordered
another Mouse I will check if it's fine
because I need also the mouse pad and
this mouse with you know kind of thing
to get used to it more or less because
I'm a player in general I'm still quite
quite out to say I mean quite on the top
there in leeches yeah yeah but not of
the level of Carlsen at the moment so
trying my best to climb you know but
sometimes I played like I played some
matches with you know with the with this
people that are very good with their
Mouse's that's you know then it's a real
problem when you see that just first
like 10-15 Moses like yeah you have to
really getting a second yeah that's
that's a
everybody cruel think you know to
experience alright here's here's less
for you yeah that's that's great one
yeah okay now it's oh yeah
are they okay they don't see better than
me it feels like
yeah so something is going okay I mean
this guy's our what is this what is
going on you know okay I know all this
stuff come on I mean seriously probably
played like 100 games like this yeah 96
at some point after before something
yeah okay cool he knows his stuff yeah
he's an expert on this yeah I was
playing this kind of six than rook of
seven I'd be eight somewhere and to be
honest now don't remember anything here
but I recognized I mean I understood one
sink in the Kings Indian sometimes is
this when you feel it it's like you
don't really need to know a lot of the
analysis and so on because you can
figure it out over the world
usually for me to take like 40 45
minutes when I was kind of you know like
and we call it in Russian likes King
like an elephant yes sometimes it's like
I don't know why is it the elephant but
it was kind of things like this we
always said that I mean you are thinking
like an elephant which which means that
you're singing a lot but it would take
me like 40 45 minutes you know to figure
out what what was my notes and how do I
get to them when I was playing King
scenes in like exclusively but later I
just understood that sometimes you can
just do the normal move that you know
that is targeting the King and even if
it's not in the notes it's not so easy
to play for example such positions if
you make something up already you see I
mean why it makes something up I guess
because 25 yeah and like this one is
going to be hard Jesus Reese coming
ashore and so on
you know like spent only 23 seconds yeah
but this one looks very good for black I
mean it's like probably he didn't do
something correct but also white didn't
play well and now he gets I mean the
natural moves just took the 62k six
breathing that everything is cool now
it's
if seven maybe and just swampers in time
into play this 78 and 25 is it's like I
mean this four bullets would be nice
okay g3 is also a queen g5 babies even
faster yeah 25 Brooks is seven maybe but
still should be fine for black some
Bishop h6 and so on but I would be more
happy to play some kind of root of 7
before g3 even now maybe work of 7 okay
everybody in 25 then to go oh maybe rook
f7 yeah this one as well but rook f7
Queen c6 Bishop h6 was possible I mean
it's such a pleasant position it's like
and this point they don't matter simply
they say 76 just you can just you know I
mean send send them as a present you
know for to buy it just you know
speakers you will made the King you
don't care about the bones here yeah so
it's just yeah it's just one year for
black all right very nice that's
actually my brother-in-law playing Oh
seriously yeah with black yeah we black
like this opening yeah now he's
completely winning yeah I mean it's yeah
and if you playing what is he playing
stronger now after the after the
birthday party what he wasn't there no
it was a different brother-in-law it was
a different City
okay I have I have many of them okay
okay yeah but this is completely we just
say extinguish so yeah so you can just
flag him
yeah just enjoy the moment if he just
has to be careful not to blend or some
mate here yeah but I mean just to play
with your sound is enough yeah and yeah
just
h3h3 and you break through yeah but even
without the pea supplement will be
probably bad alright that was there was
a good game that was a great Anya
yeah but he knows what he's doing coming
in opening this is very unpleasant
because in this King's Indians
I mean he's not only meeting you but he
also knows all this sublet is like where
tonight after the c5 and so on I I don't
know if you can see the chat if you have
like like the chat open on your yeah I
can open the tab yeah I don't know I was
just gonna say you're getting a lot of
compliments on your hair oh thank you
very much
I mean maybe no need for the haircut
until I have the hair still so yeah I
don't think anyone I don't think anyone
beat Magnus with the hair length so far
but Coronado had a lot of hair in the
last one in a clutch chest oh yeah like
like an afro yeah yeah yeah yeah and
also Anton Cordoba also came with a
really big afro once yeah I mean it's
like a Greek had like a dreads or what
is it called as well in English is it
dreads as well like when you have this
kind of stuff like breads yeah yeah and
it was famous for famous for this
picture yet like with this dress but it
was long ago it's like I don't think
I've seen it I'm gonna I'm gonna try and
find this yeah you should find this this
was this was really kind of think how
would the one I find that Greece shook
with dreads I don't know most famous
picture of Lee Shu something like that
oh really Wow I know I haven't seen that
one that is one good photo you you see
you see the one I mean there is one of
the Neil's grand alias but the other one
is of Grisha
he's almost bald but the other one is
that was dredged oh that's yeah that was
a famous thing yeah I'm just gonna save
that so everyone can see it it would be
okay if only I saw it all right yeah
that's the famous one but it's only the
players of my generation they know about
it in general I mean I think all the
others they missed this moment all right
so you know if if everyone can see it
but this is it
there you have it yeah yeah very nice
that is what that is good that that's a
good photo that there is one more as
well I mean the other one I think is
where you can see exactly that he worked
on the details I mean it was not just
for fun like kind of serious stuff like
yeah so I remember first time seeing him
like this I was kind of amazed but he
was trying things with his hair a lot I
mean like coming sometimes bald
sometimes with this you know long hair
sometimes like this sometimes short
there so yeah I think he he kind of gave
up on that yeah now he's a serious guy
alright so here we have a game where
black berserk Oh
what is next
yeah but it's okay I think he got normal
position general still I would prefer to
be white here but I mean 25 maybe some
tricks okay not maybe later
yeah but after this I don't know if yeah
he can't take yeah he can take no he
can't take the pony it could go g-force
talking about this one yeah of course
it's easier for whitey this when you you
don't have a lot of time I mean when you
have we are playing this bullets and so
on because the king is now always
vulnerable was this g5 played yeah wins
simply we shop if I was winning yeah but
this even now yeah we should be five
yeah we should be five maybe
okay Queenie for do you think white will
win I guess no I mean strictly for one
for black I would be surprised if he
didn't yeah Luke do you wanna should be
500 this ends badly
black yeah we should be 5 and that's
resigns yeah this one yeah just take
okay here I think we know what will
happen
mating simply oh and our he prepares
mate very nice yeah I like the way he
played h3 I don't know why why not Quinn
they say six
he wanted for it to be made right away
yeah but the cladistics was like also
made like in few moves yeah during take
his positions simply he didn't think
it'd get blocked oh that would be nice
green six cone f7 let's say King gauge
for some Quinn takes two six if you
would finish in a manner designed the
guy king gauge for twenty six some age
five and kanji for check H takes d4
Andrew K trade made yeah all right
blindfold port is about to start his
game so let's check out that one and
it's a new account it's still with a
question mark yeah but what is it I
can't even imagine what was dope yeah
okay okay
more or less I understand what was the
opening so yeah this one g3 was it was a
c4 e6 f4 d5 yeah nine three difference
you see five these three nine six okay
yeah okay but now what is it I mean is
he losing a roof is it
yeah and also give up a knife like one
yeah but it's desperate tale yeah yeah
g3 was too much he could go some Knight
f3 mm oh that's one Knight takes d4 you
know but this is also a very fast yeah
so now it's what is it it's a rue Cup
and the knight up okay so it's a it's a
resigns yeah alright this was fast what
else
eight moves alright let's see Yona Yona
she's playing with check out yo nosh
mm-hmm look at your sugar is sacrificed
everything in the opening
yeah the also berserk yeah but it seems
that he's very confident here yeah that
he will he will smash in this game but
now it's calculating some stuff with
kind of 95 and so on but instead just
decided to play monkey 1 now actually
black is good yeah if he would go just
Castle short
torn up I mean compensations but not
that much just fine for black
yeah and way way up on time yeah what's
going on actually what what happened to
you on the did he start with the with
some kind of if he's less time is it or
it just spent so much time I yeah if
you're new to leeches you can berserk in
tournaments that means you lose half
your time but you get more points if you
win okay so he okay okay I see yeah it's
like if you think you're dead much
better than your opponent then you
berserk and you crush them and and they
wouldn't like decline to do this like no
yep your challenge or no he he doesn't
have a choice he can only berserk back
and then if if he wins then he gets also
extra points yeah but he's like seeing
too much I mean so I think black is just
playing too strong for him maybe was it
was it plant
yeah I think that he he berserk seeing
his rating but then he was surprised
that at how good he is
oh Rudy seven Rudy sound oh come on on
the sound oh yeah only seven I have six
this is my favorite you know look the
seven ninety six is how my game against
Dingley unfinished
ah the streak yeah they look for it yeah
yeah so Rudy seven is always always in
my mind you know so yeah but this one's
he will lose yeah I guess yeah with 13
seconds easy III we should be six I mean
three years old
okay this now it's a different story now
what you win for sure was one yeah
Wow black had everything that's
incredible yeah yeah this one check and
mate even was my ball skills this I
would win yeah bad mouse and no mouse
pad
okay he's still surviving okay but not
anymore
and okay no but the guys having fun he's
completely won yeah this was I think
black gave up too soon he thought okay
this is now a win and that's just it
yeah alright let's check out so and when
we want to see the like the general
standings we can we do this I mean like
when we see the least yeah I just go way
back and these are now the standing so
just sonic is leading the tournament so
let's see if oh yeah that's already very
very progressive but I don't know it
doesn't mean at all that he will play
against their best yeah it doesn't mean
he will play against this number say two
or something yeah it's just yeah it does
it's similar to a Swiss like if you're
like first you will play with someone
who is also close to first okay
I see oh but this one is what both kings
are open but I know why white looks
weird
yeah the roof is there stuck just only
one but still it's not the end of the
world there someone asks a question here
that I also wondered myself because
everyone writes your name with a D Roger
but you yourself only write it with a J
so what what's up with that why were
people using yeah if ok it's it's weird
story in general because when we were
getting visas to go to France I think at
some point for the Junior Championships
I was going to play like kind of my
first official international tournament
or the rated term of something like that
and they were giving visas and on the
visa and on the you know for the French
Embassy they had the sign of the
transcription like the for the
pronunciation transcription zone of the
name and they were giving it to the
French Embassy and they made it like
through oh you for my first password so
oh you are so tame over and for the
surname they did G J
it is in a fiddle list and so forever in
the feeder list I am like on the first
French with you know that I have
obtained for to play the corner
yeah and in general I mean when you just
transcript it today today Azzurri or in
general I mean my name goes like Raj
without D but I'm so used to to both
names so I feel like I don't know a kind
of you know a pop star that happiness
and even though the difference is small
and it's not something you know sound
but still kind of you know kind of thing
that they're just I'm just used to it I
mean it's just like this by the password
it sometimes even very strange for you
know for some registrations that I have
to do something or or if I'm talking
about myself with some you know person
that like laughs chairs and so on and
you know we discussed something and then
I send some email and it's a different
name there so kinda straight yeah but
yeah it's like this and you know it
especially table is very different it's
a I am oh you are so it's it's
completely different and it is like it
is now so I didn't change it already was
numb with this name so I I didn't really
care much and I don't really care now
because it doesn't really change my
thoughts it's just fine but for finding
for sometimes it creates kind of Messer
yeah official I always only saw the one
with with a D and then only when I saw
you you like you have an Instagram
profile and you write it with the J then
I figured that everyone yes doing it yes
it's it's like in the passport yeah
generally so yeah then it's easier when
you have to either no prove with your ID
or something so you do it like this in
the password but many times when I'm
like some talks I'm in negotiation some
emails and so on I have to write down
that it's by the according to the list
so I feed the official list so yeah very
weird but it's like this for so many
years that I don't care anymore
I don't like pop stars have only one
name not not two names yeah but pop
stars you know do you have sometimes the
small names as well but in fact here I
have even bigger name so and the other
one is a bit smaller so it doesn't
change much but both stars I mean they
do some look for the
you know for the for singing they
sometimes do the small names you know
yeah but here here's not it's not the
case of course I'm just joking here here
it's it is like it is you know I
couldn't do much because changing it
also was a problem at the time I was
playing constantly so it would be a mess
also changing the name in the feeder
list so I mean I just said okay that's
fine I'm playing like this and also for
a long time I just had it in the
password so in the national passport so
that was that was the case somehow it's
a very strange story how it happened but
I just didn't didn't mind you know it's
like okay let it be in a French manner
in the fiddle is that's fine also it's
like feather SEO on all this decision
and so on so it's kind of doesn't
contradict through to finish so it's
fine okay yeah sometimes such things
happen yeah definitely explains it yeah
and also you know there is the story of
two case I like playing the matches for
the world crown okay but like I mean all
this two case playing the matches like
Karpov and Kasparov and for example when
you write it down in Russian like for
example if you write down like Carlson
or Cara wha
they are also case they're also two case
yeah it's no see like in English its
case still in Russian when you write
Carlson you write it with Kate like
Kasparov or Karpov and so on so it's
also kind of weird because actually it's
okay in Russian so they also say
sometimes that there is a match between
Kerwin and Carlson the match of two case
again and so on but in fact when you
look at it in English it's not two case
it's two seas okay such weird things
yeah they happen sometimes most world
champions were with okay yeah oh yeah I
guess Karpov Kasparov Carlson in Russian
yeah yeah Allison in Russian yeah so but
Allison is C so it's not not considered
there or Oh actually it's interesting
see how many they are I mean there are
sees Capablanca as well okay
so it's who's leading which name is
leading there oh it's it's actually hard
to say so it's two K's and 2 C's is it
yeah but we also have one and another
hint on an inhalation we also have yeah
but yeah yeah yeah that's true actually
so it's only two where it's like you
know the almost none of the teams I
don't remember if it's this record was
set at some point is like none of the
strongest European clubs won the
European club cups three times in their
in general I think or in a row something
like this there was one kind of record
that was not set and we were trying to
do it was now a Chess Club
the French one and I don't remember if
we managed to do this but also did sink
I mean all these records so now we know
that there are two A's to case and two
seas right is it it's actually three
case if there's also kramnik here mmm
yeah crown yeah okay yeah yeah so three
case the most is three case is it yeah I
don't know it's complicated because I
have at some point I've lost the count
when it was like you know when when they
were 13 world champions
yeah me too and I counted until they
divided the end and I yeah pretty much
stopped counting all the other ones yeah
because there were official champions
like ponomaryov and so on but yeah so
yeah then they didn't consider them as
champions because they wanted to play
against they should have played against
Kasparov and to be legitimate champions
and so on and then this was what Kramnik
did yeah so then it's complicated after
certain it was complicated but we know
certainly that there are what now 16 is
it like is there like in all times that
you put like old support rates you know
you remember probably this year when
they were only portraits of all the
champions like in the chest yeah we have
it also in our chess club and it ends
with Kasparov yeah that's in the most
clubs in the world I guess yeah girl
yeah that's what we lost so and then
somehow this story starts to be
unusual they took a usual pass with all
this division of the titles and so on
okay let's see maybe some games cause
it's yeah yeah all right
metoya versus meet me ha logic yeah the
bank oh yeah all right this one looks
what oh yeah it's a poem and also
normally black should attack but this
white is attacking somehow yeah so like
an attack and opponent up here and now
we'll just take only six in the super
classic and manner baby would take with
the Queen only six and ninety six and
just pretend that you've got everything
you want in this life and in this
opening
yeah and black is or white is also up on
time this is very bad to shop for now
yeah Niger 7.7 we should be I mean
everything's just Falls no this is just
winning here it should go back somewhere
of it
no chance okay take say six dozen or to
take a six no coming takes 27 he just
want okay enjoying himself
yeah he's enjoying a lot okay very nice
yeah okay I seeked Ronaldinho saying
that Phillip is playing my nephew so
let's check out if he is playing all
right for the moment no but that could
mean that we've just finished again yeah
maybe
alright so let's check out this one okay
this one's all yours okay this is
classic oh nice I was too old yeah okay
but this one okay okay
theory Oh just finish very fast with
basics I didn't expect this good theory
thank you very much thank you very much
guys
like one two life eight moves okay it
was a eight alright that was a there was
a crow but if you wanted to play a stick
don't you think he wanted to play six no
I think he pre moved and just didn't
they call it there should be five
most likely yeah that's also true I
don't think he slipped here all right
baby boy versus gazzarri Oh someone
someone asked for you to mention how do
you pronounce the Yuans last name like I
always Brown stood new pony she is that
okay yawns young new pony she yeah yeah
yeah okay even though she because yeah
please
no I I think I like struggle with it for
very long but I think I have mastered it
now I mean sure yeah so new pony she and
generally yeah because it's written in
this it's actually very hard to write it
down general I mean the way it's written
is also very strange I mean in the
Phaedo list as well I don't know how it
is in the password but when you read it
I think in the field is it's like
nymphomaniac she or something like this
yeah I know I know how to write it since
I do it all the time but it is like one
of the most complicated ones yeah yeah
so this one is it's quite complicated
but okay for therefore the Russian
speaking it's not a problem certainly
but it's like sometimes they're also
hard the surnames like for like the
Indian surnames sometimes they're also
quite long ones you have and when you
have this kind of you know when you have
this kind of transcriptions clear how to
really pronounce it and also sometimes I
mix up let's say like when it's a
surname and the name you know I mean it
happens with swimmers it I think with
Vishwanathan Isaac is his surname let's
say for for Anand and Anand is like is
like the first name this correct me if
it's around is the surname yeah no I
think the Vishwanatha is the surname
really yeah but I mean they're Indians I
guess in the Katya they can they can say
well wow if that's true
like I always thought Anand was his last
name
yeah can we check I mean is there do you
see the chat I mean they will probably
tell us the truth
yeah I do see it I'm pretty sure someone
will will mention it okay yeah they say
Anand okay some say our name some say
it's the name so they it's also device
so you can yeah like oh so many of them
are divided oh no Alan is the last name
they say yeah which is the father's name
okay okay so I yeah sorry for for for
kind of misunderstanding but that's okay
but I will at some point yeah like it's
weird a lot of people are saying that it
is the first name but I'm still gonna
think it's the last name no I know this
the last name this is yeah yeah the
father's name okay clear clear yeah so I
okay I got it wrong because all the time
I was saying that you know that yeah but
yeah yeah okay okay so it's clear yeah
okay it's clear now also in my mind
because I was also always confused as I
was thinking that I don't is a surname
and once I was told that no it's like
his his first name so should be written
vishwanadh an a instead but in fact yeah
it's good that I finally solved this
solve this puzzle after so many years I
know him quite well I never never asked
him I mean it would be kind of okay yeah
it's like his name is Aaron and
Vishwanathan is the name of his father
so that's yeah like pregnant but Ramesh
Babu is his father and then that's not
like his name or his last name I I
believe okay and then they say you know
no it is an aunt he's a first name okay
I am confused again
no no we've solved it like usually yeah
and I saw some comments yeah but he's
only Anand like that's it and then which
Martin is the name of his father so
there's no like name and surname okay
okay so so it's just silent and that's
it and there's a name I believe so yes
I didn't leave so okay now it makes
sense why good confused about all of
this was complicated yeah okay thank you
thank you everyone in the chat yes panda
thanks for the contribution panda says
that this is so interesting to listen
that he stopped playing yeah I mean no
but I mean all this all these things are
like with the surnames it's like for
example in Spain they say you know this
Jay they say with it like like hey when
even when they send you the like they're
laughing or something like or something
like nah haha like we do is H let's say
and they do with Jay Jay Jay and like
Jay AJ AJ yeah yeah for example when I
would come to Spain and so on for a long
long time I mean even after asking me 50
times how you should pronounce it how
you should say they would say at a hub
of like in almost all of my games like
they would say that against our AHA both
against that I half of all the time and
then they would ask me I mean how should
we pronounce and I would say that Java
and they all say okay once again read
Java yeah okay and then I would hear it
again and gain again 50 times and at
some point I said guys I give up I like
this raha boosting so you just say like
as if your answer line yeah yeah because
especially I'm used as I told you with
it like with all this surname things so
I said okay Rahab oh for whatever it's
fine I'm just like really yeah I like
her hub of sons very yeah sounds like
some fun is going to happen yeah so it's
okay so what is this game
he lost the bishop okay yes but it's
it's again a flag off so it will be
decided by time who is playing this game
that is a good question it's a game
between again still baby boy versus
gazzarri 94 all right let's check out
the standings and we have Gonzaga Suraj
and it's quite a position so let's see
what's happening here
I think it could be just or no probably
edges meet get a rookie into the game
just brings the rook and resign sir yeah
you know let's see what's the next move
because otherwise he just made he will
play some Queen G - I guess when it's
lost but still well he played no oh it's
actually actually the best most probably
but that still Queen G for a new key to
just resigns I guess just queen g4 and
rookie - okay will he play it Oh what oh
that was a mouth sleep ugly that was a
mouth sleep I guess yeah that's why he
wanted to play play 25 further yeah yeah
look if I were which is not the best
move because couldn't you do is already
defending something but still he's
winning
yeah but here oh now it's down the rook
now it's not the time to be upset it's
time to play super fast
yeah yeah maybe maybe I just aged 5h4
whatever just just don't look at the
board and move the pieces I mean the
pawns whatever you have there just have
4 h 5 h 4 it doesn't matter because it's
so lost that you should just play fast
so it's g5 I guess h5 whatever h4 yeah
yeah and I like black yeah actually also
like black practical yeah after this
after this it's already again unclear
okay okay it's some Queen d6 maybe
look if two white is winning generally
but we will not resign you Toby thanks
for the contribution
he says it's 4:30 and he can't sleep
yeah that's okay and now Queen there may
be okay okay it's just winning here King
give soon just resigns it was very wild
Queen d1 Oh Queen e8 media a queen d1
yeah sorry yeah yeah Quinn g4 was also
mating but it's faster this one and a
white offer the row here
this happens sometimes yeah I mean the
players are referring to drawing this I
don't know it sometimes happened to me
as well because I want to click resign
and then I accidentally click offer a
draw
ah there is a flag instead of so you can
sometimes mess it up yeah yeah me how is
playing let's check out his game against
freedom Esther Madhavi yeah but this one
what is it oh but no but black is much
better now but stop is there Bishop a5
ok yeah I mean chopper if I was the
Mafia yeah and he would make you take on
these three after Bishop a5 no it's oh
no it's he will lose this maybe no it's
too dangerous now if 2 is hanging oh now
it's bad I guess
yeah no it looks really bad the wrong f1
maybe or something just to protect
everything with some quincy one later
bang Quincy one
yeah no chances
take steaks tonight whatever 94 maybe
yeah he doesn't want to trade
yeah but Quinn is 3 I'm not sure maybe
some Bishop d2 be shopper for trying to
stop this you know to close this up in
age to be 8 no nasty yes I I do read the
chat yeah I do all right
no but this one now looks good for white
I mean it's jumping also has this check
on g6 that's annoying
on the next one just check on g6 and
wins the peace which peace Queen g7 2007
King just say on Knight f5 checking at
age 4 okay yeah that piece is glued one
good piece yeah but this yeah now again
I mean becomes unclear wow this is three
key now some Ruby 2 is coming mmm yeah
it's not so easy oh it's yeah I think he
did something wrong but no okay it
doesn't matter anymore
oh now it matters because 21 wins he
doesn't want to take any one okay rook
takes e4 no fix it for was possible try
to complicate yeah now again of texador
oh no oh.look takes e4 know he wants to
be mated quintics he doesn't okay
yeah I couldn't expect this quintics of
40 didn't play
no it's me no white we all know that was
way oh no it's great yeah
nice but generally they're they're very
strong for for missing the squint a
except for I mean Queen takes it one and
then I think they're playing on time
mostly they're playing so many games
that it's like that it's already doesn't
matter if you take the route not it's
just just the movie business
I mean sometimes your happens just to
see if you know a nice blink ah she's
playing let's see if what's this
oh it's it's already over we're gonna
check out a game that's that's just
starting my girlfriend is also playing
so we have to check out one of her games
as well alright let's check out this one
okay so Bruno house again it's quite
comfortable here because now she's
playing and you're free to do the stream
and stuff this is just completely fine
yeah she's always playing she's always
playing it's like all of your family's
playing as far as I understand there and
they Serena yes is it like nephew the
brother-in-law is it yeah other
brother-in-law sisters Weller yeah
like the inker chess club is the family
pretty much okay monopoly on this chess
Irina yeah okay did play f3 and through
the 84 Ashish press the thanks for the
contribution he says I love a job of
dairy thank you very much thank you so
much and David Kimora thank you for the
refreshments yeah no okay that that's an
interesting question someone says
someone asks what what can people expect
from your channel like maybe now and in
the near future or having maybe you
haven't even given it any thought
oh no I have some ideas but they were
like kind of different ideas engine
I mean it's not my thing too much to do
like Waqar does in general it's not not
a bit what I wanted to do on the
channels and I wanted to be a bit more
like kind of specific about chess and so
on which I understand that may not
attract many maybe too many people
because I mean it's less fun and so on
sometimes because people need some fun
as well
and I want to mix it up no no I mean
that it's not I mean if you look at the
key cards that say streams and so on
it's there is a lot of fun yeah it's
like tons of fun it's like the fun found
and fun and so on there is no I mean
there are no analysis of the games and
stuff and so on generally Las Vegas yeah
yeah it's it's fun it's very good for
chest certainly I mean because I mean it
makes it more popular all the streamers
are playing coldest you know the gamers
sold this you know pillar all people
online they're playing there so I first
generally wanted to make all this games
that I I saw that are important for me
in general and do this the champions I
did first first three on the channel of
this as part of unarmed and Carlsen and
then wanted to finish all this saga with
the World Cup which was the like biggest
win in my life so it would be just
generally I mean somehow I don't know
how I structured it but I structured it
like you know the wins against the most
known let's say the world champions in
the world and like the greatest
champions in the world and then do this
you know the World Cup and then see what
I'm going to do about the streams many
live streams for the chess tournaments
to comment on chess but like generally
specifically I like chess you know like
more more chess related than I mean you
know like not making like a lot of the
collages and like those and everything
there from the streams it's a bit not in
my style I maybe I'm too old for this I
don't know but yeah so I just want to be
specific about chess so and like to have
people but you know this specific things
on chess I wanted to do some kind of
opening stuff as well like Kings Indian
and Sicilian just for the players of the
of the you know like the different type
of players actually because I think that
it's it can it could be used for example
if I do like the Kings Indian course or
something like
or the Sicilian on all the stuff so I
saw that they can learn a lot from it if
they really want to study like the game
and the opening center one so I was
thinking about it as well so also wanted
to make like I said the streams for the
four tournaments like the big ones
especially where I'm generally it's not
the fact that I'm participating there or
not participating waiting there so just
the big tournaments are important in the
chess calendar beat life or beat online
I mean beat otogi be online and beside
it I thought about interviews with like
the greatest chess players but of course
I would prefer to do it in life you know
in life yeah and yeah because I think I
have a lot of stick to us from the
different world champions I wanted to
ask them and actually we had different
like you know friendly talks behind
stings and I wanted part of it to be to
be available to the public in general
because there are a lot of interesting
things that they can share and people
know about them so it's like kind of
kind of you know the classified
information that you have in the CIA or
whatever and you disclose them after 50
years but I wanted to make it a bit you
know earlier than this so I would have
liked to you know interview some like
really big top guys like maybe kramnik
and all the others that were available
for this but I will say I mean how it
plays out because now it's very unclear
resolve the situation with the with the
virus so it's not possible generally to
travel and yeah I think online is very
different than this because while you're
like kind of having a live conversation
with the with the person certainly you
cannot say that you want to be in the
interview don't want to you want to cut
otherwise online you know you will have
to stop for every five minutes and
discuss something and so on so it's it's
not possible to do all these things so
generally I just start with all this and
then see what's what and how it's going
on but certainly I need quite some time
for this because I'm also working on my
chest so also now online tournaments are
played and so on and probably if the
classical starts I will have less time
so I will see how it goes and how much
time it takes generally and then just
decide what kind of things and what else
I can do
but this was the initial plan so I
didn't really make like a huge plan was
not like a Hollywood movie know that I'm
screwing you know they were making the
plot for it but just generally
interested in like general chess and
probably that is interested in you know
in chess analysis and chess self trying
to improve in the game learn the
openings see the players talk about
important things in subjects and things
in their life maybe like you know the
world champions about their matches all
the skilled in situations that we don't
know much about but many top players
know about it and so on that can be
available like through the like
interview talk or some kind of direct
talk with with the champion or the
candidate or something so some kind of
stuff like that yeah I want to start
with you yeah okay I don't think you can
be too old for some like that like I've
seen there's this gentleman he's I think
65 or something in his streaming World
of Warcraft so I don't think yeah I
don't think ya Antonia of course I'm not
saying his bet it's very good I mean
it's very good also to popularize
popularized chess and it's fine but I
don't know it's just not the thing I
wanted to do I just want to do something
more more specific about chess and
understanding fully that it's less you
know it's less attractive probably to
the public because sometimes just want
to relax and watch something funny with
chess included there and so on and so on
and so on or somebody for example one of
the possibilities I thought about the
streaming is for example very nice I
like it in general just the streaming
like playing on the online like like we
do now for example the analysis of the
games or when you are playing yourself
let's say against the I don't know top
players or puzzle rush or all the stuff
this is interesting this is very
interesting like for me yeah some other
stuff I'm not sure I'm just maybe I'm
not capable of doing that maybe in jail
is just not I think I'm not sure I
didn't really try so I don't know but in
general I don't see myself in these
things I see myself more in a bit more
you know specific hair stuff so yeah but
we will see how it turns out I'm not
sure now I never say never you know some
things it was not for example going to
play bullet ever I thought in my life I
was told that
even bleats is not that great and then
I've I mean all my life I spent playing
bleats so I was just fine and already
now when I'm sure these three I started
to play a lot of bullet bullet games so
so if you see me next time on some
unusual stream for me then I'm just fine
with it so I just found the way to do it
and my place in it but I don't know me I
don't see myself there so I we'll see
how it turns out so yeah that would be a
bit more specific about chess I'm also
interesting because I'm analyzing and
all this stuff also I learned a lot from
it
I think even Magnus told last time that
he's very interesting we're very
interested in this analysis that they do
and the course that they did for for
some first time she has site and so on
to you know to kind of lecture or
something where he really learned a lot
out of this lecture zone so I also
learned together with everyone because
I'm looking the analyzing with compete
all that stuff I mean it's interesting
for Mia for for now okay so for the
super long super long answer but just
trying to it was it was it was a tough a
tough question
mrs. near-misses bureau says that who
are where your most respected players
throughout history throughout history
yeah there's a long one
no there are so many players yeah but
some of them I didn't know I don't know
at all and so it's hard to say but yeah
Carlson is in the list for sure kramnik
Anand well if it's if we were talking
modern times generally because certainly
I didn't see Fisher ever in my life even
though I know a lot of people that I
mean interact somehow with him I mean
knew him and so on
Judit even like worked with him for some
time and many players played against him
of course Carson on first I knew for a
very long time like we had a training
session as well so when I was young I
mean when I was a kid more or less I was
10 or 11 or something and we had a
training session
played a lot of glitz games we've
studied a lot I mean really a lot of
stuff I had this love for the French
defense he was also the adept of the
French defense always like like the
opening and yeah was fun sessions so of
course he's a very respected as a chess
player as a fighter I really you know
think that he's one of the greatest in
history even though he didn't become the
world champion ya know I mean all the
world champions in general they're very
interesting personalities like
characters and generally if you say like
as a person Kramnik who's cramming and
anant they're very friendly in general
always so yeah so it's very easy to have
like all the small talks with them
discuss anything in the world
any subject more or less and they're
very intelligent people and like you
know very very funny in terms of you
know trying to talk about different
subjects so I mean it's kind of fun
always talking to them of course if
we're talking the champions I don't know
depends what you're talking about who
exactly wasn't the champions or I just
generally did yeah I think it was a it
was a it was a pretty vague question but
I think you you covered yeah I think I
mentioned already too many players yeah
yeah already too many players but
certainly I'm sure
like for example Dahl was a great
personality I'm sure I mean from what
I've heard and all the stories and so on
I think partly yeah I mean he was he was
kind of I mean she was super champion I
mean all this this match against but
Vinick is just something that every move
is just different you know because you
were taught to play classical and now
cause the player that just plays
something very unusual looking at the
time like kind of stupidity but in fact
it's just a great play was you know
supported by the great tactics and just
change the entire world of chess you
know and change the entire you know
perception of the of the what is the
classical play or the understanding and
so on and how tactics matter and the
rest branch Dana's it was a great one as
well I mean if you want to study the
games like
of the most exciting players it's darlin
Bernstein
I mean his first names that appeared
there I mean when you're just thinking
about it because we're stayin was also
kind of great guy and his books are
amazing I don't know if you read a lot
of his books I woulda made his comic is
it oh he missed it he missed it I didn't
but I I started with the Wonder 1953 the
great oh yeah I've heard that one is
like I've only covered the two games and
then I stopped I was planning on
covering the entire tournament for the
channel no but even in the first two
games that I've seen like he explains
like a lot of stuff like - well even for
for my for my skill set he says I don't
know when he explains the weak squares I
think in game - I think it's some game
between Karras and night off I think he
says that a lot of other grandmasters at
that time did not really understand weak
squares and then he just explains it in
the game and it's like I mean it's a bit
overwhelming yeah but I mean he has some
books in Russian as well where he plays
I think David against Goliath or
something like this that where he
explains his play against computer and
the engines of his tire they're like I
mean recently more or less it was like
okay more more or less recent book I
mean I don't know maybe end of 90 maybe
to thousands or something something like
that I guess around and yeah he was
explaining the you know the games and it
starts from the first move and he starts
to explain oh like all the suppli to his
house he sees the game and all that
stuff I don't know if it's if it's
translated to English but it's something
really outstanding it's like I mean it's
like I don't know it's not it it's not
all about like you said like all the
subtleties of the lines or the openings
and stuff but it's like all together
kind of like a fiction book and the book
on openings the book on general
understanding the way the engine sinks
about chairs I mean all the aspects of
chairs are just taken to the whole new
level and with the different perspective
and generally just I mean unbelievable
when I was reading it it was like a
fiction book plus chess book was like
everything in
in one game is you know analyzed like if
it's a movie or something Lord of the
Rings very unusual yes seriously I mean
it's like I think we miss certain guys
like them I mean this brush stained or
tile to explain chess in a different way
you know I mean some kind of like genius
touch or the you know the kind of vision
that they had towards the game towards
the positions thoughts then they're
standing in the way they were looking at
the game you know it was like kind of
every game was kind of the celebration
for them of course they were nervous
they had stresses they played matches it
was hard and so on but it was a
different perception it was a different
kind of airs they were different kind of
professionals because now professionals
are like you know the stubborn guys were
always citing a lot of theory like
looking at the positions know a lot of
stuff and so on even don't sometimes
certainly creative but we still can't
compare them to to Thailand to Bernstein
they were like fantastically
fantastically you know kind of creative
guys you know like every position would
be like kind of painting or something
that they would think about and find
some unusual I didn't know it's I don't
say that now nowadays players certainly
the top elite I guess it's much stronger
now than the elite of that those times
even though it's very bad to compare
because they didn't use computers so
it's I mean it's unfair competition as
well I mean we we have made a huge leap
in the theory we have made a huge leap
in this you know this technology that
works with the gather with the chess
players in a home preparation so on so
it's it's very different but I mean this
guys they were I can't imagine that for
example Fischer will be much stronger
now compared to what he was at the time
and he would dominate the rest of the
field who is a big even bigger gap
because he was more or less alone
fighting against everyone like in the
Soviets let's say and on the chess board
you know doing this alone when you have
only the chess board and that's it
but imagine him having the engine I
think yeah
he will be extremely strong like ten
times stronger than he was at the time I
mean that's what I feel I don't I don't
say of course is weak and we can't
really make an experiment on that but
I'm sure he would be because I mean
alone he was studying and was playing
very closely to the computers level and
who was out without the engine don't
forget about that just playing you know
almost alone sometimes with with some of
these coaches but sparring partners but
not that much compared to the Soviets
let's say and he showed them I mean
fantastic and understanding and you know
the games of the quality of the games
it's amazing so I feel that the champion
like Fischer for example of his time may
be tall as well that I'm not sure
because computer would probably not
influence well he's kind his type of
play yeah but Fischer I think he would
be a much improved version of because
imagine Thalia sacrificing all his bases
and getting defended in every position
like he would just have a disbelief in
his attacks he would the resign chess
yeah who maybe say like at some point he
became kind of played like this when she
was playing already in Montreal I think
and he was he was kind of player he
would say that you know I would beat
myself when I was 20 years old like I
don't know ten zero in every match but
it's not true because he was super
strong in this tactics and you know the
passion to win the game and to just
smash the opponent and destroy and you
know but do it like in a very beautiful
manner as well I mean it's unbelievable
I think I would be very happy to let's
say to to have some kind of just a
glance on the way he was approaching
chess in his times it's very hard
through the interviews and so on because
I mean it's different perception
certainly so someone asked here in the
questions how did you how did you become
so strong at such an such an early age
like what was what was your recipe I was
I mean there is a there is a part of it
certainly lies I guess in some kind of
talent that you have towards chess but
suddenly I mean and I did a lot of work
I mean I was working like real
heart so I think like all of the chess
players in general that are up there at
the top let's say not even now but if
they were at some I mean some time ago
or ever I mean I think they worked a lot
so there was a lot of work and maybe
also depends what kind of work at the
time because for sometimes you just work
on chess but you know it's Ori I mean
let's say you're studying only openings
and then you're just bad when you are
playing your own chess you just general
chess when you have some unclear
position out of the opening or some
other move that you have studied and
then you are kind of freaking out
because what do because you just know
the theory and all that stuff you have
learned everything but you don't know
what to do when the play starts so there
is a kind of balance that you have to
find out for for yourself and with the
coach maybe in my case it was my dad who
told me and later I was also always
studying his game and beside it also
studying with some masters like
international masters that they were in
Baku and of course I did a lot of like
lead sessions I've played a lot of games
I was not really studying much the
openings at the time which some said
there was a crucial mistake not to do
this because you don't know the classics
of the openings and so on and then you
miss big part of chess and you can never
be good at it and so on but at the time
it was great I was only playing Knight
f3 d4 and then I had two ways of playing
when I was a kid that was playing some
kind of d4 eastery then Bishop d3 and f4
and it was a stone wall like reversed
because I was playing stone what was
black and I was doing all the games in
the Junior Championships so I liked it
so much that I was playing the same with
white and it was a like a pillsbury
attack or something
it was d43 bishop this rendered for the
same thing then at some point was that
we realized that it doesn't work that
much because they still study games they
have already bases and all that stuff or
at least the politics of the tournaments
and so they would see that you're
playing this so they will react well so
I started to play some kind of stuff
like 9 f 3 d 4 B 3 all the systems and
since my childhood they became kind of
kind of my main opening but
certainly when they moved to the
classical super diamonds I had to change
something in the repair tour and learn
the general theory and start to plate
this so general general advice would be
just to study a lot I mean seriously but
I mean a lot of tactics a lot of you
know solving is a lot of looking at the
classical games there are paintings but
do it like you know like a kind of
general thing not not just one thing
not just tactics and you don't know what
you do in the opening at all or but it's
better than knowing what to do in the
opening and not knowing what to do in
the middle game like for example
position like this it's better if you're
a tactician
with both sides then you are the super
transition that will just sink here for
one hour and play a three and resign it
always better it's not always better
because sometimes for example when
you're on the on the higher level let's
say already
I mean you mean do you mean like is it
always better than what like to be then
grab dinner you know that you're a
better tactician than a better opening
procreator let's say but sometimes it's
such a far opening preparation that it
can be better than your tactics because
everything is learned and you just get
very bad position and even if the guy is
less strong than you in tactics
okay I'm not comparing that like I don't
know 2736 and 2100 tactics let's say in
this case but I'm if we are comparing I
mean more or less the players of let's
say the 2500 player 2700 player if you
get in a very bad position out of the
opening and the guy is like really no
series super far then I mean it doesn't
matter that you're better in some
aspects but many times it can and
especially nowadays when the series
somehow is far for example in some some
kind of night off let's say was you know
Bishop g5 let's say you don't remember
one move you just can resign and end up
and go home or stuff like that so it's
complicated but if you compare them for
example if you take the top in general
more or less the players know what
they're doing and opening there in
general good in tactics then some are
very good some are a bit worse but maybe
they're better in some strategical
positional play or so and so on but now
it's more like they try to be trying to
be
you know generally well-educated in all
the aspects of the game because now if
you are playing badly surgically or
tactically normally maybe you are not on
top I think so but also openings they
matter yeah generally I agree with you
that the general play the general play
is more important but also general plays
is part of it because when you are
learning the openings you learn the
middlegame structures as well because
you're from the opening you are
transferring to the middle game so there
are a lot of things that you understand
by studying the opening so it's not very
much connected the opening and the
middle game that's why it's hard to say
that you can now be a very strong chess
player without learning openings because
you don't know some typical structures
some kind of you know the typical ideas
you know this weaknesses and different
openings the will handle the bishop or
the knight in a specific position so
it's kind of nice to think nowadays so
it's middle opening and the middle game
is very connected very much but it
doesn't come without you being a good
tactician good a no strategical player
and so on so now players are I mean
they're good in most of the aspects in
general I mean if you take the top let's
say it's hard to say that everyone's a
good technician there are no bad
technicians yeah generally it is like
this but some are just more technicians
than the others and the others prefer
let's say some kind of calm lady for
example with so a lot of times that
Carson's winning like kind of very
coalition's just on domination of night
against the bishop or something like
this things like this he's more let's
say the technical player in some aspect
and he tries to clarify the position
more than others let's say and then
let's say I don't know bhashya graph
let's say he prefers more tactical kind
of play or and so on but it doesn't mean
that if you put my Sheila Graf in some
kind of technical and game he will be so
bad that you know every in game you
enter with scheme is just good for you I
mean certainly not so he will be very
good at it
as well but sometimes when you see a lot
of games like 10 games or hundred games
of cars and you see that there is some I
mean some technical art prevails and say
in some aspects then there are four
yeah such things you can see sometimes
but now it's less and less I mean more
more the players become more kind of
like playing called the openings knowing
some stuff everywhere and both tactical
and positional players you can't really
clarify what kind of player it is so
yeah now it's less clear because
everybody studies with compass knows a
lot of theory and it's different simply
I mean for example like Fallujah let's
say he's he's more tactician you can say
that he likes all the streaks and so on
like all of the staff tries to
complicate tries unclear and usual
positions you can see it like
immediately but more and more he will
approach the top let's say he would be
more consistent in different types of
play so he will you will see it less
than that he's prone to play tactical
games only or just put subtle tricks or
something so said some tricks you will
see that here towards this kind of
semi-classical type of player maybe with
some preference to the tactics but still
semi-classical he will become it's it's
it's a must generally there is no like
tiles anymore like just tall and that's
it yeah but now with only online chests
happening at the moment his style is
definitely a strong one certainly and I
don't know if now that all this you know
coronavirus situation will lighten up
and everything and we will have more and
more classical tournaments I don't know
if there will be less online events than
there are now so players might be
conflicted where to play in the
classical event or maybe in the online
event yeah but if the Magnus Carlsen
tour continues and it collides with some
big events I don't know maybe players
will enjoy playing in his tournament
rather than let's say a big over the
board tournament off of the same size
and maybe maybe even the same money
prize yeah but I don't see a way that it
will collide I think it will be just
different tournaments in totally they
will not collide on the dates and as
from what I heard
from Magnus interviews and generally
that I know I mean from what I've heard
in general from other players as well
the idea was to make this tournaments
played when there is no classical chess
so that was the idea okay yeah so it was
kind of kind of thing that you do when
we can't really play the classical chess
that was the point that was the the idea
and it's hard to imagine that for
example when we have this Oh chip events
why not organize this type of events but
ODB I think it would be a great idea to
make kind of Tour like like he did but
over the board and I am sure that a lot
of players miss classical just for
example I I myself I mean on my own also
I would be very happy to play in the
classical tournament in general because
you have this different feeling and so
on but this online tournaments there
there very good thing for this tent we
have now to still be in professional
chess and you know play all these
tournaments and I think it's a good
thing anyway but they can I hope that
the best hope I think for the entire
chess communities that they keep these
tournaments together with the classical
ones they don't overlap yeah that would
be great that would be I mean amazing
thing because this one it's like a 1
million dollar store I mean not many
tournaments have this kind of budget in
general even though GP tournaments and
yeah it's amazing yeah but I think they
will try to combine them and they will
not put them on the same date and so on
if they if they still manage to make
such tournaments in the future I'm not
sure that they will put them any kind of
you know there will not be any kind of
you know this swords for the top chess
players if you play there or there I
think they will not decide on this I
mean it will be just clearly different
tournaments I guess yeah hopefully they
will stay hopefully but I mean we will
see what the sponsor say also after this
tournament I don't have any feedback
probably they have of course for example
Carlsen he's he's also like involved in
one of the platforms so generally he's
contributing to it a lot as well so
probably he will keep on doing this
because I mean
I mean revolutionizes in some way this
this this platform so I think it's I
think it's it's the the thing that he
wants as well so probably this will stay
yeah having this feeling I don't know I
mean it's hard to say because I know his
plans and I don't know the feedbacks of
the sponsors but I did at the moment if
they give 4 1 million dollars for all
this tournaments I guess they want to
try at least so why not it's very
important for chess yeah it's for the
entire tour it's 1 million yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's that's decent was coach
s in there no I think not no it was a
separate yeah I think it was a it was a
separate one I think it was the Magnus
invitation of the Italian Doris now the
third one will be the accessible masters
I think it was called chess masters then
they renamed it the chasuble masters and
then maybe yeah so all together is like
close to one in the half millions in
like a few months this time more or less
that they found on this I I think it's
like a million for five tournaments it's
for the tour is it yeah yeah but if we
take into account the Clausius it's not
it's not alright now I don't know if if
clutch is a part of the Magnus tour
I think it's part of the cell loses club
or something so yeah yeah yeah it's got
a sink built and so on so yeah so we
imagine I mean this one and a half
million just came to chest like in few
months more or less all together if we
combine all these prizes yeah I think
it's it's easier to give a bigger price
fund for an online event I think there's
just less arbiters less everything less
accommodation less much less here you
just give everything into the prize fund
and the rest is organized yeah it's
completely different but and there are
different problems as well with this
year
yeah one thing I hate about online chess
is that there are no photos of players
like
high-quality professional photos of
players from tournaments which is
something I very much enjoy yeah that
would be
in pajamas here yeah just just the the
webcam and you know yeah I seen his
shorts and stuff like that but this is
possible to improve this in general I
think I think it's possible to improve
on this so it's it's a matter of time
how would how exactly would you improve
on it I mean all everyone has like the
great cameras or something but not the
video quality video quality the cameras
in general maybe make some photos from
the different angles that can be you
know can be done you know the distance
you know by the some computer guy or
photo guy sitting together and doing all
these shots during the round yeah I
don't know some things probably they're
possible to find and maybe in some cases
in some countries maybe the situation
will be fine as well so they can take
some photos let's say I don't know in
Norway and then when the situation
improves in some other country I don't
know it's very hard to say now it's
really complicated with all this
situation I mean but for now it's a good
thing I mean for chess it's a great
thing circle I was surprised very much
that he found so much so much
sponsorship so fast for this tournament
is very good I mean it's a great sign
yeah even I I really felt like it just
happened overnight yeah yeah it was like
this is a cancel the candidates are
cancelled there's nothing happening now
the Grantchester is cancelled and then
all of a sudden there are like
tournaments for the entire year
happening yeah like here is the 1
million ok guys
yeah let's are the serious yeah I can
edit no ok so we are not looking at the
games but we have to okay but next time
we join we are going to concentrate more
on the games yeah yeah but I mean it's
fun to talk of course that means
certainly it's pleasant to touch some
subjects because it's not it's not only
about the game certainly I mean it's fun
to watch but and it's like so many games
here as well at that you can concentrate
on all of them yeah my my brother-in-law
is asked
me it's his birthday today if he can
play a one game against you after the
tournament is finished yeah yeah of
course of course if I'm not sleeping
here the tournament is over in 15
minutes okay so yeah of course I'm sure
and but then we will discover your
secret leaches handle or oh yeah yeah
yeah actually yes yes I can make another
one um yeah where I can yeah I can play
against yeah we can do the other one but
maybe with some other platform we can do
there yeah we will do that then maybe
yeah you you almost blew your cover
so yeah yeah you almost blew your cover
by by accepting the challenge yeah yeah
but I just saw that we can do it
anywhere in general but I don't then
yeah then you got me back to earth and
no no of course at the last moment when
I'm entering the arena I can oh but I
have a way how you can do it I have a I
have a genius way how you can do it okay
I play with his handle no I'm going to
challenge you into a game and then you
will you will tell me the moves you want
to play so it's like so it's like a hand
and brain only you choose both hand and
brain okay one of the possibilities yes
yeah
as you command I think I think that will
work well all right this is this is his
second present actually he already he
already got a present you're working
harder at this but did he make a good
present for you oh yeah he always makes
the the best one like like I got a
compilation of of my best games well not
just my best but my games from like a
10-year period condensed in one like a
notebook with photos and with tournament
standings and with well it was just very
very time-consuming so to say
yeah okay what's happening we're looking
at the leaders or not no no but it is
from the top 20 I would say okay it was
all right
it just takes everything you take do oh
no no but also the point is that for
example when we discuss this like online
chess is for like the spectators
understanding I mean it's very different
like compared to the general chess like
that you play OTB for example sometimes
when you see let's say you have played
the game even like on the chess board
OTB game and then you share the same
game on the diagram it's a completely
different story I don't say about
reversing the board like you know for
example the game like this it looks
absolutely different I mean when it's
how to say the concentration and all
that stuff it's very different when you
play it for example like this on this
kind of board like on there this is the
way we work on chess normally like like
yeah diagram boards but for example when
you are playing is really very different
I mean when you feel the pieces you see
the pieces on the board it's different
perception so for in a long term let's
say I think there is a difference when
you play for example online chess rather
then you play let's say like the
classical Oh TV for example the Blitz is
also very different that you play I mean
online on the diagram with the mouse and
so on you don't feel the pieces you do
it with the mouse and it's like you have
kind of I mean in my case let's say it's
like having the less control in general
one case of some other people it's kind
of you know that I mean the mouse
matters the way you move the pieces the
way you don't want to blunder with the
you know with the mouse all that stuff
just a bit distracts you in a way I
don't say generally changed the results
of course I mean around the world as you
can see I mean from both the top layers
they will still perform well on the
unboxing rhiness they will still I mean
they will get used to it and sometime
forceable when I started playing like
bullets okay yeah okay this one was cool
just meeting yeah but I mean when I was
four
example starting to play like on this
like the bullet online okay I felt like
it's very hard because of the mouse I
was always not on time and so on
but then still you just find some kind
of tricks that you do like you're
changing mentally getting used to
diagram positions and so on to play
chess on it move to pieces when you need
just just for you know okay this one
missed night for you yeah and you move
pieces fast and so on and you get used
to it and then you see that
okay now you're performing like you
should so it's kind of strange saying
that at first let's say the top players
they can come to some kind of chess and
at first maybe they are not performing
as good as they should but then they get
adapted like in to the I mean to the
controls to the mouse to the way the
board is because also the board on
different platforms is different such
small things they matter let's say on if
you are playing in the long term like
online chess and so on
you have to get used to all of these
things because I mean I think like for
example the board of like chess comb or
I don't know chess 24 they're very
different if you play it on on both I
guess right yeah so on one the chess is
big for example on my screen on the
other one is very small on the other one
I mean you know it's you see it
completely differently so you have to
adjust the board all the things they
matter for example the camera he prefers
some special kind of board as you guys
have seen through key streams mm-hmm for
some kind of special pieces special
board and so on let's say if I would
play on this board I would maybe not see
as much as I see let's say on the normal
one like like this let's say or some
other so which kind of thing that you
have to get I mean adapted to like you
know to get used to it and so it's kind
of tricky sink and also when you are
playing let's say online tournaments
they also differ a lot because I mean as
I said this the board is that the fact
that you are not moving the mouse I mean
you are not moving the pieces but you're
moving the mouse you are not pressing
the clocks you don't feel the opening
and kind of you say it you say it like
you know you don't feel your opponent in
general the emotions the way he reacts
your move you don't see what he feels
during the games generally so only maybe
when the camera shows also it's not it's
not the same thing so it's it's
complicated I mean we're far from
getting the same experience like in
classical ODB so at the moment but so
yeah we're trying hard so it's not bad
as I said it's kind okay I mean I I love
online chests of course but I really
really prefer the over the board chest
much more you know the you decide when
you pick up the piece and everything you
just move it it's a lot more enjoyable
yeah yeah but do you feel like do you
feel like you would be stronger in a in
some way you know let's say over the
board game or in an online game like do
you feel like you have more control in
over the board game much more much more
control like really much less and in in
on online games like I just just feel
like like this I mean when I'm on I mean
over the board I feel that I'm
controlling like the time the way I'm
playing and so on and here it's like
yeah of course I'm trying to control
some of the things certainly I mean it's
not it's not the end of the world but
the control is very different there for
me a completely I can feel good maybe
for NACA let's say is not a huge
difference to be honest I think he's
used to it he's playing so much and he's
probably better online he's a very good
online he's comfortable as well and so
on I'm more comfortable when I'm playing
qotb in general I mean certainly it's
like big matches and so on they're
stressful but still I mean it's it's a
different story I mean if you compare it
let's say I mean compare my online
skills of laying I mean they're not that
bad but I can't compare my bliss skills
like over the board with this one I get
more concentration more motivation
somehow I don't know why this happens I
have to think about it but yeah this is
a serious difference you know for
example when you are playing for example
some kind of blitz World Championship
and so on sometimes I can get back the
great shape after I lost like few games
and when for example playing online and
I lost some games I just I just can't
come back and normally I don't feel like
I will come back you know like
just different feelings and there you
just walk around and you do something
you just come back again you touch the
pieces differently and then you start to
play different and somehow you get this
kind of you know you're shaking yourself
and saying that okay you should do this
and that and somehow you're getting back
and maybe this feeling of the pieces I
don't know that you move the pieces with
the hands and pressing the clocks
sometimes you do faster sometimes here
you always do it more or less routine on
the same with the mouse and so on you
don't feel that you've made the move I
don't know for me it's a different
feeling I was not a fan of playing
online since there was this ICC internet
Chess Club and playing yeah and somehow
I stopped for a long time didn't play
and okay there was so many only beasts
there there was no no need but then when
everybody started this chest calm this
events and so on it started to be more
popular and a long time I didn't enter
at all because I just didn't like this
kind of thing no it's not not my natural
thing but now I can realize that I have
to work on it I mean just change my
perspective from this and try to do
better but it's still not the same I
don't I don't feel that I'm controlling
it the way I should I don't know if you
if you understand what I mean or no I do
I I also prefer over the board much more
like yeah I feel like I'm having more
control simply yeah yeah that's that
there's no better better way to phrase
it than that no okay so what what is
this okay this one he's attacking was
black even though he's too poor Daniel
yeah he has to but not a good one yeah
or maybe yeah and also can can black get
the dead Bishop into the game somehow no
but no they don't need it okay they
don't need it but they he didn't have
too many most abused them it's like when
g4 and then Bishop vegetal yeah I wanted
some hard 24 and Bishop d5 yeah
peace out and it's a very important game
for the standing so he will play it out
he
well he will ask for for a checkmate
okay even that very nice if only it
wasn't the pawn it would be stalemate it
would be a stalemate yeah yeah okay so
this is the standings five more minutes
till the end so let's check out we
probably have time for two more games
and then it's a tournament is over
so leader feeding master blank
thirty-seven versus column 2007 oh he's
leaning there the blank blank Saracen
yeah yeah is the number right to his
clock is the current the current
standings yeah if you hover over it it
says Korea tournament ranked yeah so
what's wrong
Ronaldinho says he is preparing very
nice no but this one is uh what is going
on I have now a double check 94 yeah all
by Queen g2 and you sacrifice the night
or no
when you mean Arthur King just me yeah
just take you to maybe okay
yeah but then okay yeah yeah it's a
check on me no no I mean it's a check to
White's King here yeah yeah and also the
night has been so yeah but also just
Kingdom but also just queen g2 King g3
King captures therefore I do I do you
don't have G father I thought gee if I
was checkmate okay yeah it's still far
from it because can you series awesome
yeah yeah yeah okay so we still have a
bit more time let's check out the game
by someone we haven't seen you post six
110 okay with we haven't seen his game
yeah again against blank okay so we
accidentally chose a game against the
leader again uh-huh so it's the next
game official yes it's up again so fast
doing this I want to learn from this guy
yeah no I'm serious nice like 10 most in
his piece
not completely winning again it's a
blitz specialist probably yeah I mean I
don't know somehow he's doing this super
fast and collects everything look at the
way he now hit rate and let's check and
capturing the Queen you will play some
f3 and probably be very happy about his
position yeah or that
yeah who the seven somewhere now maybe
what he wants Ruby for but it's not much
but at least some chance Ruby for
Simon's forum but through the sound yes
the guys the guys monster will take it
to seven now even possible ah
and then Bishop yourself a shoulder shop
afraid added they've both berserk now
everything is for that a couple of last
points okay so yeah but he's not the
phrase of Queen g7 yeah but pooja fall
and blank okay yeah yeah that was fun I
don't know he's uh he's doing it right
somehow she's getting cold dead when she
like so fast so he gets the first after
winning this pretty sure but maybe there
maybe there is time for one more but I
don't know if anyone can catch up to him
will probably will probably see but all
right so he takes this win and yeah he's
first with 80 points and there is a yeah
physics is good with 74 but he doesn't
have the flame you see he won more than
three in a row and now he has the flame
if you have the flame then you get extra
points for a win like you don't get two
points for when you get four and if
you're berserk you get five so I don't
think anyone will be catching up to him
so we can check out one more game by him
as
yo Sara was doing extremely well but he
lost his last two games yeah so this one
is uncatchable right the blanks
uncatchable he's playing again and also
has chance I mean in case he would lose
the game would say yeah so weird that
every time I show like the last game of
the tournament and the stream it's
against Bruno that's amazing last time
was it again yeah I think it was a house
versus Bruno was the was the last time
we've had it
oh but this one is also comfortable for
him just play before and all this stuff
yeah I still bet the real yeah I think
yeah but the guy who really plays good
chess and you know so I take 593 winning
again you can even stop this no but I
mean he's like no really bangle just
simply I mean from what we saw at least
yeah
night is coming yeah okay and this one
he will page six now retreat somewhere
yeah 25 h5o splink you know good chess
can I say fast strong I mean look Queen
f6 25 more ok and now how now to realize
the the extra pawn yeah oh yes dry
exchange
nobody will convert it smoothly I mean
step 6 of 24 every system no I mean the
guys playing just good chess I mean I
don't see how he he will not win this
was just yeah
it's destroying
yeah I don't know what to say
this guy's where is Nick Turse style on
whatever scope is yeah
what is the nickname of Magna Steyr yeah
I think it's the doctor he has a couple
of them but I think it's he was going
with the drunken Stein for a long time
but then he switched it to Nick Turse
Stein I think that's like the sober one
in Norwegian ah so he was drunken Stein
first yeah and then he switched like
Nick Turse Stein I think it means sober
but I could be wrong okay and okay we
have one more second in the tournament
and that's it there we go so that's the
tournament has finished ended the winner
is fede master blank 37 from United
States I don't know if he's playing this
anonymously or not but no it's just in
Chen he's 17 years old with a peak
rating of 2340 it's very good chess yeah
very good chess congratulations Justin
Chan very impressive
second place physics is good and third
places are of congratulations guys and
the rest of the top ten are you post six
110 video master janosh MB freedom
master super gm1 Casaus yet column 2007
Archer 23 and Siddhant I am 29 and I'm
gonna publish both both of this and the
winners of the meadow arena in my next
video so make sure to congratulate
everyone and what we're gonna we're
gonna play that game against Ronaldinho
okay yeah of course okay so I'm gonna
challenge him and then you just say the
moves so we don't disclose your secret
identity you can also play bullet and
that will be fun when I will be telling
heroes
oh yeah that will be fine what time
format do you want
I know any but not two to two hours for
40 moves no no like three minutes five I
don't know I don't know as you wish what
is better
Trini yeah that's what you what do you
want to play I'll just check him in the
chat 1 0 is also good I will tell you
the most
ok I will probably I will probably play
it play something that you haven't said
ok he says 3 is 3 ok yeah ok of course
ok let's see ok the the legendary clash
Ronaldinho vs or a job oh alright
and the challenge is accepted alright ok
we start here yeah do you see it okay
yeah yeah d4 ok all right here for c4
yeah mmm ok
oh my god ok night of 3 we will lose on
time it's sure 9400 you know stuff 95c
takes ok no I'm feeling that I'm
controlling nothing at all
III should eat - ok let's go
it should be too
the guy knows all the stuff for what is
what is going on
hiding okay so let's go about an
all-night 563 okay
five to six green I can resign I'm sure
all right so this one looks not that
good to me especially the Kings Indian
player
okay 92 let's see okay let's go
g4 okay let's have some fun
if we lose we lose and fires yeah at
least h4
g5 all the way I tell you it was this
game at least it will be invite H new g5
ok Knight d4 Knight de for ya all right
Knight takes e5 Bishop yeah yeah alright
quindi safer
okay we're losing on time simply can we
go something like f3 maybe are you
asking me or telling me yeah I think I'm
telling you but not sure now because
we're too slow as Freston a would say or
Carlson who's telling that you know
Group G one maybe let's go now G one do
you want
I'm more asking you because I'm not used
to playing this kinky - yeah I've never
tried this actually
now it's it's intense yes so II for
Queen f6 Bishop III
remove rock AC 195
rooks is seven
94 Oh be fast please GC 196 iccpicc
classy
okay okay sorry it's okay it's okay 96
okay
king of 297 pre-move d6 Ruka chuan chuan
to catch one I know it's your nephew but
still okay it's a long board for if
oh this is too intense
d7 96 96 okay okay now it's taya it's a
time for you to play I think because 98
98 98 98 Roxy 809 797 knight of seven
yes a king f3f3f3 okay
d8 Queen da Queen d8 queen
wait no why did you remove for me he
resigned but he was going to win this
game for sure yeah yeah yeah yeah but
that was a very unusual experience I
think we're you know we're like the team
of we're like did some of these two guys
when they're driving you know on the
yeah and the right one is saying
something but in fact if I will be on
the right side I sure we would lose all
the all the you know all the races food
this was super stressful for me and I
wasn't even playing but you see it's
it's what the online chess makes out of
the person you know it's like yeah you
are stressed out because you can move
something or somewhere you don't see
what your opponent is doing and yeah in
the real chess when you see yeah here
this moment here you just hear it was
clear you're playing your nephew why
late night xd8 I'm sure it's all fixed
and pre-arranged after this yeah okay
anyway it's fun yeah but thanks we
didn't accept the 1-0 challenge yeah
yeah so no but that's fun but we can
actually do this this stuff maybe let's
try something to set something up like
you know always wanted to do this maybe
you can do this in jail as well there's
a blindfold chess and stuff on the some
of the platforms blindfold yeah every
platform has it the blindfold right yeah
and the spectators they see the real
board do they I don't know I just asking
because it's it's a different type of
interest when you see the chessboard
just the general chessboard and how it
is in real and the one that is blindfold
chessboard I mean of course it's much
better for the spectators to see the I
mean all the pieces on their squares
normally yeah it wouldn't really makes
sense with a device it's not fun at all
because you're not following anything
it's like I mean you don't know you have
to see it like on a different board like
for example there were this amber
tournaments I'm sure you are aware of
them December's like yet we were playing
like Rapids some blitz and as well the
black Eiffel chess and the point is that
after you have played the mindful chess
then you were coming to the normal game
and then you would play in this normal
game with all the pieces on the board
you see them and it would feel like the
any positions winning with most colors
because you see the pieces now I mean
it's it's so easy now it's much better
and that's why all all the guys they
were I mean coming there for the first
time for this tournament you would just
come there and lose almost all of your
games after you have you know after
after you have played blindfold because
you feel so excited that you see pieces
now and everything is fine that you just
simply play so badly in the normal game
you also all read the fact that your
opponent is the pieces you know not only
you and so you just get you just get
this kind of positions and everything's
looks fine after this and at some point
I remember I was playing Carlsen in this
blindfold game and I won a piece I
tricked him with some some kind of
combination or something and he lost his
bishop and I was having something like e
six is seven or something promoting to
Queen a completely winning and we both
knew that I'm completely winning but at
some point suddenly it happens this
sometimes in the blindfold chess and the
very complicated games and so on I just
forgot where all of my pieces are and
I'm just seen I'm just thinking I'm what
did I do how did I manage to forget
where I mean most of my pieces I forget
where they are exactly where is the
Queen where is this and that and so I'm
just moving you know II 6 e 7 and then
he resigns because he thinks that I know
where everything is and I was happily
just celebrating to win but sometimes
this things and so I mean it's very
different from the norm
yes like we play like online and so on
but I think it could be a great fun fun
as well
yeah any playing we should do something
like this
sure especially if the spectator sees
the board normally this is important I'm
gonna I'm gonna have to check up on that
as I'm not sure I because they tried the
blind for chess once I tried it like
four bullet and something just to see if
it was possible and you can click on the
squares but I don't I don't know where
the the other position would be for the
spectators well yeah but it would be
strange you two if it will be also
blindfold yeah I don't think it would
yeah probably make no sense yeah I'm
gonna have to I'm gonna have to check
for that because for that to exist the
website that would have to have it like
implemented especially for streaming
because without dreaming it wouldn't
really have any purpose yeah but that
would be interesting to set it up
somehow because it's fun it's like it's
still I mean a very good game sometimes
were played I remember on this blindfold
tournament something even better than
the normal ones but it's a lot of fun
when you forget for example in one of
the positions in the Sicilian Wilier had
a 685 pawns
like like in the position we see on the
board like instead of beep on he had the
pawn on e5 and at some point I was
singing on my move then you know with a
very intelligent face I went night b5 he
just took a takes b5 and I said ok ok
goodbye and the whole game you know just
went astray so in the end the rapid was
where Karpov blundered Queen to unit
polgár like he just yeah like it's just
too costly Queen f1 or something and she
just captured it with the rook or
something like that
yeah but also the this excitement of the
following such games is that at any
moment the blunder may come like like
just any moment compared to the more or
less generally good games in the rapid
and so on even though there it happens
as well as especially when the time goes
low but I mean you don't compare it to
the because here anything can happen
even kind of winning position can be
ended just in one move because you
forget where the Queen is or the bishop
is
yes there is a there is a simpler way
you can do this online like you can just
put on a blindfold and someone else
makes the moves and it's you don't even
need the blindfold option you know yeah
but it's somehow more fun though I mean
when yeah the player moves himself this
once and yeah I thought should be I
wouldn't know but most likely yeah yeah
I guess but I don't know yeah it would
be nice but especially like two on two
in one position or something like that
when it's getting too complicated
because you just follow you're like kind
of your friends moves you more or less
follow them if it's possible to make it
like with the cameras or so on that you
see that what he did so you have to play
it out in your head and the play out you
know the move of the other openings you
see what I mean
so it's twice as complicated so will be
much more blunders probably because you
will see the move of your of your like
companion there's blank but really like
partner okay so it's you you feeling
sleepy tired or are you up for another
another game we have one more challenge
before we end the stream if you're
feeling yeah okay let's do it let's do
it alright let's see if you're really
still here but we're gonna do it like a
five-minute a game now okay yeah yeah
okay all right
yeah three is just in three I'm just
gonna ruin your game by pre moving okay
let's play for alright
no but it's it's anyway still it's like
you know it's like twice what I was told
telling you night of three now it's not
that I'm not even moving the mouse it's
just I also have to see what I'm doing
CC let's say yeah it's a weird D for
yeah but it's only because you have a
secret a C takes yeah yeah I guess it's
only because you have a secret identity
well I mean depends here because I mean
you think it's that if I would play with
my handle our they are much faster yeah
at least yeah so e5
okay
okay this is interesting so let's say
nice history all right
already hard to say what is this so
let's go Bishop b5 let's have some fun
Bishop b5 is having some fun all right
kind of kind of him some okay what else
here mmmmmm
let's go oh oh my god I have to work on
my chest Bishop III let's go alright
[Music]
that's actually maybe a good move h3
let's say alright Queen f3
alright I guess I mean I wouldn't go ggf
would be a towels mafia yeah and we're
talking about it and then f4 g4 yeah he
would go something but do you remember
this G takes f 3 against but winning you
know what what was it caro-kann or
something and he took G takes us free
caro-kann I think G for now G for yeah
ok it's not whiskey or anything it's tea
by the way because everybody is asking
me like taking this year is it because I
mean for some I think I did some life
with Kuryakin or something Bishop takes
c6 okay and they were asking if it's
something else than tea but it's not
I don't know fortunately or
unfortunately what kind of tea just
black see a black nothing special yeah
okay watch what should we do now
let's go can we have some fun h4 maybe
okay
hmmm this is already very very intense
it's hard to say what's going on to be
honest
at least after tea yeah if the the
weirder Sicilian it's a very very
position I don't know what's going on
that's very good to hear
yeah I don't I don't really know what's
going on to be honest yeah probably I
didn't do
h5 let's say okay okay what's this
no it's interesting okay
yeah it's interesting what's going on
yeah glad I'm not playing this game
okay let's try some h 6h 6 ok in the
style of alpha 0 kind of bad alpha 0 I
would say in the style of very bad alpha
0 in the style of Rahab oh oh oh yeah oh
yeah
that sounds more to the point okay let's
go Castle short short castles alright
what do I say there thanks for the
contribution man okay let's go Luke from
rental meant let me see Luke a ec1
all right let's sacrifice something or
someone
so let's go night it'll all right
I see what you are doing very good not
sure actually but it's so good mm-hmm
it's interesting okay let's go some okay
he's playing stronger so what can I say
let's go some Queen - G - let's see what
what's he's up for yeah okay he's
playing very strong in jail I like his
chest actually it's playing very good
it's my fellow Kings Indian player yeah
he is he really loves the Kings Indian
f4 all right
okay let's go um say okay let's say King
h2 okay yeah II takes f6 okay yeah okay
let's go what do we go here
night-night to g1
oh we're bad on time again as usual
yeah that's the usual sing night of 395
if takes e5 this should take C 1 B
should be 61 okay Bishop b3 Queen f1 o
Queen d1 not playing a good game simply
it's just fire
[Music]
kingi three all right for this is super
super intense queen f1
oh he gave us some time Oh Queenie - he
gave us 30 seconds
very very gentlemanly yeah she's a
gentlemanly ace real moment yes real
let's say
[Music]
Quinn f3
that was very bold with the queen bee
three no I think it's okay Jerell wild
Wow he's playing really strong I mean
okay what is this King H for let's say
can we do the CLS go
it sure seems like a plan like kabedon
mmm I like it I like badlands
yeah especially in quarantine she when
you have Badlands Queen let's say if six
yeah he's great
bravo Bravo Bravo G takes f five king to
whatever
Jesus ryoga's G to
no just g3 yeah when software the cool
let's be fair that he played a great
game okay we offer a draw I know he
wants the Oh
she was licking just three come on we're
old guys here to playing one game oh
yeah oh yeah yeah but we really barely
save this yeah thank you sorry for the
game but it was a great one especially
this Quinby 3q industry and 94/95 stuff
yeah it was I thought he he couldn't go
for the four that you to to abandon the
f6 square but but no but he gave us 15
seconds he gave us 15 seconds no 30 30
ah he gave us 30 seconds yeah 15 and
then I got 15 more yeah in that position
it's like donation yeah a big one they
tipped us see I should start playing
from my account to try to be just earth
in a matter definitely I think that okay
we will do something about that thank
you so much for the for the stream thank
you it was really pleasure yeah and
thanks for joining hope to hope to have
you over for some more chess and fun
some sometimes yeah I will also have all
this banter blade sessions and so on so
everybody's welcome to come there yeah
talking and playing on this before the
Magnus tournament or after depends where
the schedule puts me there yeah okay
thank you so much for the stream thank
you okay later man yeah I still don't
know how to exit this I think it are we
still life yes we are okay so basically
I'm just gonna Congrats thank you
everyone for joining and congratulations
to everyone who played who won the
tournament we're gonna publish the
winners like I mentioned and see you
next Friday for the arenas but we'll
probably be seeing each other more in
the streams over the course of the next
week so see you soon guys and
we'll be now publishing a new epic video
by aagama Torino so to check it out it
will be live in like maybe five minutes
so thank you and thank you bye thank you
tamer